remember the days when Britain ruled the
waves house is a maritime nation history
played out on the high seas from the
days of the mary-rose to the Falklands
and our economic health relies on
Seabourn Freight so how come we find
ourselves all at sea having gone from
being the mightiest force to sail the
oceans to a vanish Armada and having to
plead with allies such as France Belgium
and Denmark to help protect shipping in
the Straits of Hormuz after Iran seized
a merchant tanker sailing under the
Union Flag since the Falklands conflict
in 1982 the number of destroyers
frigates assault ships submarines and
virtually every other type of vessel
available to the raw Navy has been
decimated embarrassingly the one type 23
frigate we do have in the area needs to
return for maintenance and another
scramble to the region won't arrive
until September new p.m. Boris Johnson
has said he was a fan of military
modelling kits as a boy but it will take
a lot of cash to air fix this problem is
he ready to spend it yeah so actually
this feels a bit like watching someone
look through a telescope the wrong way
because just for a bit of scene setting
here with what happened with the Iran
crisis a few weeks before that UK ship
was seized actually Britain seized an
Iranian oil tanker just off Gibraltar
now that oil tanker was not was in
international water so there's an EU
agreement that says the U position is
that it can act within 12 nautical miles
of the EU coast which that ship was not
so so for the Iranians as far as they're
concerned that ship was seized as well
if we pan out more widely what's
happening here is really about the
nuclear deal the international agreement
from 2015
with Iran and lots of other players
including the UK the u.s. decided to
step away from that last year and as
imposed sanctions on Iran which has
crippled them financially there are food
and medical shortages they are now in a
desperate situation Britain's so far has
upheld its arrangement with Iran because
as we say so it's a signatory to that
deal but it is now being encouraged by
the u.s. to stray away from that in a
way that we'd be damaging not just to UK
reputation but to this internationally
agreed deal which is very significant
and very important that it holds in
place before I bring Gration just in on
your curriculum would you be happy
briefly to spend more money on the
defense budget we don't need to spend
more money it's the wrong but it's the
wrong question
surely the point is we should have
thought about this before we picked up
the Iranian ship and took it over I mean
what's the point of taking our Iranian
ship if you then come they're bound to
do something back to you and we then
can't protect it yes I'm not of the view
you want to spend a lot more money on
really armed forces because I think
history tells us that prime ministers
particularly Mr Blair because we had a
bigger four armed forces like going to
war and actually we are not we're not
that great maritime nation memory school
the minute if it is no longer called the
Ministry of War it's called the Ministry
of Defense I put it to you Greg that
we've now got to a perilously low level
a Makati trying to defend again we be
for defense short because I don't think
we can even do that no we should we need
to look at what do we need for defense
but in this case we as I understand it
we were encouraged by the Americans to
pick up an Iranian ship and surprise
surprise they take one Rachele s in a
minute Rachel Rho Rho Joe Brady we need
to hear the statement from the royal
from the Ministry of Defense and what
they say is the Royal Navy plays a
pivotal role in maintaining freedom of
navigation around the world and in
recent weeks our presence in the Gulf
has deterred attacks and protected a
significant number of merchant ships HMS
Montrose has accompanied
thirty merchant vessels through the
Strait during 17 separate transits
traveling 4800 nautical miles in the
process I think - just picking up what
Greg says I think and the cache question
I don't think the answer to this
particular potential crisis of this
choke point in very important shape
point for all international shipping
which is actually if it's closed off
could cause a global crash because so
much goes through those streets I think
the real issue is who is running our
foreign policy we've got a void at the
moment it who is actually in charge
during the seizure of these vessels who
who ordered the seizure of grace one in
July was it actually the Americans or
was it Jeremy Hunt we've got a sort of
vacuum at the top we've got personnel
changes in the two key departments as
you know Foreign Office and Ministry of
Defence I've just changed so my I think
the issue here is not really defence
investment it's actually diplomacy it's
a failure of diplomacy I've never heard
a site like it Carol I will come now
Rachel why do you known and grown and
Sian I actually agree with other Rachel
on this because you're asking you're
asking the wrong question that what
should the UK do how should the UK
respond to this situation defence
spending has been stable for the last
five years this requires a diplomatic
response one arm of that is perhaps a
europe-wide
maritime alliance and the other arm of
that is the EU European countries are
now trying to look at a ways to ensure
that Iran is not economically crippled
by those US sanctions because that's the
worst thing that can happen
look at that deal the deal that we have
the deal that we have with Iran is
basically sanctions will be dropped if
you reduce and agree to have monitor
your nuclear supply if sanctions have
been reimpose then what's to stop
drowning and flailing here because I'm
more worried about the defense of the
United Kingdom and actually if you throw
me a lifeboat because yes I absolutely
do think we should be spending more
money on defense and it's a fact
statistics show that countries that have
more weapons get into less wars than
countries who have less and that's
effect where but I think we also have to
and we've got to spend more in defense
because for way too long we've been
dependent on the US for cover
they spent 3.6 of percent of GDP on
their budget we spent 2% Germany 1.2%
and who do we go to when we need up who
did we go to this week begging captain
Han for help from Trump occur to escort
our ships through the Straits of Hormuz
we went to trump and we went to America
because are you surprised she said no
because for the last two or three months
has been a barrage of insults from this
country not least from Kim Derrick our
ambassador and what no but let me finish
when he came for a state visit for
private metal magicians hahaha why
should he give us help now okay let's
bring Rachel a person if you're looking
at the long-term defense of the UK which
I am my my answer to you was they did
have the UK defense in mind one of them
one of the reasons why the international
deal with Iran exists is to reduce
nuclear proliferation obviously that's a
good thing obviously it's a great thing
if a country like Iran complies with
that not just because of her arm because
of the message it sends to other
countries if we have a country violating
right can we just sends the direct
opposite message which is why some would
and see what he has to say he's that
he's a defense minister if we want to
continue playing a role on the
international stage bearing in mind that
threats are changing all happening
believe but just beneath the threshold
of all-out war then we must invest more
in our defense including our Royal Navy
our Royal Navy is too small to manage
that our interest across the globe if
that's our future intentions and that's
something the next Prime Minister will
need to to recognize you say you're very
bothered about the future around I'm
very bothered about what happens to him
what I saw the other day Frank Greg when
you hear a defense minister one would
assume surely well he started it with a
knife didn't they if that's the role you
want us to play
Carroll for once what do you mean for
once for once it would be nice if you
didn't interrupt if if that's the way
you want us to play he's saying we need
to spend more money I can believe that
that isn't necessarily there while we
want them to play